[Applause]  we would not drop like does that happen  everywhere you go it happens everywhere  I go but the most embarrassing place had  ever happened you know I like football  so I went to I think it was the Giants  football game and at halftime you know  you go to the men's room well in the  stadium's you know the men's room that  they have like 500 guys in there at a  time yeah so I go in there it's my turn  and 500 guys start chanting Joey well at  my age I don't need any more pressure  gosh I say I'll be right with you all  right I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this